so this this film I think especially now
looking at it in a way I think is a real
monument to rivers legacy too as an
actor and as a presence I'm I mean I
like many of you have seen a lot of the
work that he did I still feel like it's
his by far his greatest role and I'm
wondering I mean what is it like to look
at that now and I mean it what I mean
he's kind of an enigma now because we
lost him so young yeah you know um I
mean I think he was already like just
this amazing actor before he did this
but I think with this film he was you
know he was able to have an effect on
what the film was becoming and I think
that I mean in the case of other times
I've worked with actors as well it's
very exciting because they're actually
part of it and I think that might have
like you know just kept him excited and
everything every day and when he came in
and so he could you know do his best
work and I think it's because he was he
was part of it part of the decision
process he was sort of like I mean as a
person sort of like a Kennedy or
something he would get in the middle of
whatever the problem was
if he saw some troubles he would he
would get involved in the middle of it
and tried to negotiate or try and like
you know help the situation so he yeah
he I think he was very excited that he
he could control his for his character
the destiny of his character you know
what do you think you you got to know
him pretty well I understand well well I
have seldom seen a young actor like that
I remember one night he said to me
Hunt's be going now to the real hustlers
and I put sunglasses on so they wouldn't
recognize me and I give you a hint who
you pick out and we go to Jake's was
very elegant restaurant bar in Portland
and you interviewed the boy and
I want to listen okay so I went there
and then River said this one no so we
took him and then I said to the boy I
don't want to have sex just I pay you
just let's talk a little bit and then
River was sitting in the corner with his
sunglasses and he's beautiful here like
that and just listening actually I was
interviewing the boy and of course I you
know I had experience so it wasn't
difficult to ask what was the worst he
ever had to do things like that
and whoever needed it for his
performance he needed it to know about
this and that's I think that somebody
goes that far but for me it was amazing
and it's like he was so so much into
this part to not make a mistake and he
really wanted to know and everything I
think it was I was really very sad when
I heard on the news that he died so so
young but he was one of the biggest
talent I have in that age group I have
to work with